this video is sponsored by atlasvpn
are you out of shape here download this
app to your phone to get a six-pack in
30 days are you short on cash here get
rich quick by following these three
simple steps is your life objectively
worse due to constant traffic jams
2-hour car commutes and lack of public
transit due to decades of auto industry
lobbying here let's make cars
self-driving
30-day fitness apps get rich quick
schemes and self-driving cars all have
one thing in common they offer a
[ __ ] band-aid solution to a complex
difficult problem it's the appeal of a
quick solution where you don't have to
change your unhealthy lifestyle and you
don't have to rein in your
out-of-control spending habits you can
keep doing what you've been doing no
need to change anything just add this
one quirk thread trash fire recall
lifestyle and it's suddenly a success
story self-driving cars are the societal
version of this with one exception
instead of not changing anything they
would actually make things much much
worse how is that possible let me
explain after a word from today's
sponsor atlas vpn atlas vpn offers a
service that encrypts your data and
hides your virtual location from prying
eyes it helps you protect your privacy
and allows you to bypass those ever
annoying region locks with atlas vpn
you'll be able to unlock all that
content locked away from you arbitrarily
only based on your location like on
netflix and other streaming platforms
all you need to do is open the app pick
a server and that's it atlas vpn also
includes a breach scanner function able
to tell you if there are any data leaks
associated with a given email address
atlas vpn also allows you to block
unwanted trackers from websites with
their new tracker blocker feature all
you need to do is flip the switch
currently atlas vpn is running a huge
discount for their 3 year plan for just
199 per month with one extra month for
free using the code adam something and
of course with a 30 day money back
guarantee the link is in the description
atlas of course runs both on desktop and
mobile and is compatible across all
well-known operating systems protect
your privacy and don't let region blocks
stop you take advantage of this discount
today by clicking the link in the
description thank you for checking out
atlas vpn ads like this helps support
what i do and now back to the video
i have already made a similar video on
self-driving course when i responded to
cgp grey and his american brain solution
the traffic my question to you cgb grey
is how in the name of christ will a
pedestrian cross this and this video
will be expanding upon that so why
aren't self-driving cars a solution to
traffic issues and why would they make
things worse let's take a look problem
number one self-driving cars don't exist
wait what if self-driving cars aren't
real then what's this or this or this or
this i'll tell you what those are
prototypes and test vehicles ever
wondered why tesla's famous autopilot
and full self-driving capability is
actually just an advanced driver
assistance system that merely reduces
your overall workload as a driver to you
it's marketed as self-driving but
legally it's only driver assist so tesla
is not liable if the car causes an
accident when you aren't paying
attention why you should have because
elon musk told you your car is
self-driving we simply don't have full
self-driving capabilities yet and i'm
doubtful we ever will
all right youtube it is confirmed i have
hit that pylon um it's the first for me
to have actually hit an object on fsd
and it tried to go down the actual
railroad track on the right there
this makes right hand turn
now i'm gonna stop it
yep
yep that's very unfortunate i'm gonna
report that
and just so we're on the same page a
self-driving car is one that replicates
the skills of a safe and experienced
driver in any situation at all times
without failure if you want to know how
far away we are from this just look at
videos of teslas almost killing their
passengers by the way the tesla
autopilot is set to switch off one
second before impact so tesla can keep
claiming that the autopilot was off
during the crash otherwise there are
simply too many potential objects and
obstacles on the roads for an algorithm
to deal with sure a calm suburban street
is easy to self-drive on but the world
isn't only made up of calm suburban
streets and i mean teslas often can't
even deal with proper road
infrastructure after how many years of
development now right problem number two
just one more lane the big meme going
around urbanist circles is just one more
lane bro just let me build one more lane
i swear we're gonna fix traffic just
build let's build one more lane just let
me build one more lane just let me fill
one more lane i swear i swear i swear
that's why we're gonna fix traffic just
just one more lane and just make it
bigger just make it bigger we're gonna
fix traffic it's gonna fix traffic it's
gonna fix traffic it's gonna fix traffic
this refers to the phenomenon called
induced demand meaning that building
more lanes would only make traffic worse
if you have a clocked two lane road and
widen it to a four lane road for a few
months traffic will flow better until
people catch on to that fact so more
people take their course for more trips
so the road is clogged again the route
is then widened to six lanes and the
same thing happens to the point where
even that 20-plus lane monstrosity
called kt freeway gets jammed during
rush hour okay so if there is such
demand why not build even more lanes
that's because you cannot physically
build as much capacity as it would be
required if everyone took their cars
everywhere not to mention the
construction and maintenance costs cars
are the most environmentally unfriendly
most cost inefficient most wasteful way
of transporting people not to mention
all the space wasted by cars also cars
ruin their own infrastructure if you
build a rail line it can last for more
than a decade without any major
intervention roads on the other hand
sometimes don't even last a single year
adding more capacity only causes more
traffic as we saw in cgp grey's video if
we completely switch to self-driving
cars we can achieve maximum efficiency
on the road since all cars will be
coordinating with each other but let's
recognize that efficiency increase for
what it really is adding more capacity
and adding more capacity only causes
more traffic so congratulations by
converting all cars to self-driving
you've successfully made traffic wars
problem number three forest for the
trees people obsessed with sell driving
cars fixing traffic failed to ask
themselves the very simple question why
is there so much traffic in america to
begin with other countries don't have
problems like that at least not that
level and the answer is that u.s cities
were built or demolished four cars
subsequently public transit was
eliminated in most places sprawling
car-centric suburbs were constructed
everything was stretched out so that the
nearest grocery store is on our way on
foot and your workplace is at the end of
a two-hour drive in such places you have
no choice but to use your car thus
increasing traffic add tens of millions
of people to the mix and you get traffic
in the u.s which people are now
proposing to solve by self-driving cars
but those aren't the solution those are
just more of the same the real solution
would be to rethink and rebuild american
cities to densify to create local town
centers reachable on foot and of course
to build out working public transit
self-driving cars are just a cop-out
it's a way for us to avoid the
responsibility of changing our towns and
cities for the better and do not have to
change our precious wasteful lifestyles
but this is only a recipe for failure
you can train all you want for a few
weeks with some app but if you have a
sedentary unhealthy lifestyle eating
junk food you will never get into shape
you can follow as many get-rich-quick
schemes as you want but if your expenses
are out of control and you don't have
any spending discipline you will never
become wealthy we can turn all cars into
self-driving but if we don't change our
wasteful car-centric anti-human way of
building cities and infrastructure
traffic will never get better as always
in order to achieve positive change we
have to make an effort and self-driving
cars are just a way to avoid our due
diligence so don't expect self-driving
cars to solve anything they cannot and
will not human-centric walkable urban
planning and public transit will so go
and see if your area has any pedestrian
friendly initiatives on the ballot that
you can vote for or a transit rider
union you can join or if there are any
town hall meetings you can take part in
and advocate for walkable human friendly
neighborhoods and also tell the audience
to go watch my videos and as always
thank you for watching and if you like
my content please consider becoming a
patreon till next time